>>The climate conference in Copenhagen has
been discussed here very
much in Davos and we are -- to me, it's very,
very important that we
don't give up.
Don't we don't feel it's over and over now.
I think this year should be used to realize
that we did not obtain what
we wanted to get but then we should not forget
that we have to get it
still.
So this conference in Davos, I think the green
economy has to be
accepted a new way of having a economy of
the future.
The green economy will create jobs and will
have ability for upon the
climate.
So my hope is off to Mexico next December,
that we will not forget.
We still have to get results in the climate
conference journey.